un autre cortège contre le pass
vaccinale celui du mouvement les
patriotes des centaines de personnes se
sont donné rendez vous place du
trocadéro c'était tout à l'heure à 14
heures elles ont pris ensuite la
direction du 7e arrondissement pour le
chef du parti et candidat à la
présidentielle florian philippot la
mobilisation contre le pass sanitaire
repart à la hausse
c'est très important parce qu'on voit
qu'il ya un espèce de narrative qui
s'écroule en ce moment il ya les spahis
des et on va traiter le comique comme
une grippe y allons à l'onu ni qui
retire les toutes petites maigre
restrictions qui restaient en france on
voit bien des voix qui montent comme
rahall ce qu'il fait des millions de
vues en ce moment parce qu'il dit la
vérité on met le professeur môme qui a
changé d'opinion un qui dit des choses
intéressantes contre le pass vaccinale
on voit la grande grève à l'école c'est
un historique on voit que nous la
mobilisation est reparti en flèche vers
le haut on a eu le record historique la
semaine dernière des mayas ont foulé
donc très important au moment où ça
bascule au moment il ya six cent mille
français aujourd'hui qu'ils ont renoncé
à leur passé à terre ce jour même c'est
le moment de pousser deux fois plus deux
fois plus fort deux fois plus vite s'il
faut tout tenter maintenant mon espoir
si tout ça est validée si ça passe c'est
que ça disparaisse le plus vite possible
et que les responsables et coupables
soient ensuite traduits devant la
justice mais la justice du peuple
aventure
la mobilisation continue oui regardez le
monde beaucoup plus de monde il ya
quelques semaines c'est énorme oui on va
le faire dans l'union sacrée moi j'en
appelle à l'union sacrée que chacun
prenne ses responsabilités que tous les
candidats à la présidentielle contre le
pass vaccinale prennent leurs
responsabilités pensent à leur peuple
avant de penser à eux c'est tout ce que
je veux